together hi my name is Kelsey and I like
to eat I'm confident in my skills as a
foodie I watch a lot of those Netflix
cooking shows I don't I'll be fine
how hard can this be my name is Adam
Fleischman I'm a chef restaurateur I'm
the founder of Umami Burger you know
I've been cooking burgers for 10 years
now and I'm pretty confident that I can
come up with something out of these
ingredients I'm an improvisational chef
so gonna make it up on the spot and get
chaotic here all right let's get started
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay first I'm heating up my candle aka
my oven to melt the butter black handle
Wow complaining already all I hear is
excuses are you the kind of chef that
eats while he cooks yep Oh what my
onions are cooking this isn't saying how
this actually works oh I got a sizzle
yeah that's the good stuff that's what
they give you on the airplane oh you're
smells good does it see aren't you
supposed to stall from high so it
spreads farther you want to wing it on
there rain it's obey weight yeah so
Fayette maybe with my fingers would that
be smarter probably be putting avocados
on burgers I'm not a fan of it I am NOT
and I said that because we're in
California and people put everything
it's just obnoxious I think I have
tinier fingers therefore better tiny
skills therefore better tiny chef ah my
onions are burning Oh No ah we got our
first burn [ __ ]
don't look at my mess I'm embarrassed I
think any more wine
I'm looping my bun here with my homemade
press why are circles the hardest shape
to make they have no corners we use
these little circular ring molds like
all you need to do really just do that
just kind of go nice well you're not a
perfect circle want to kiss my mommy
sauce still working I forgot about bacon
and we're going pretty one thing we have
going for us never make a burger on the
grill I know what we'll do it because
you don't get even heat distribution and
all the flavor kind of falls into the
grill if you're gonna come on the grill
just take a cast-iron pan put it on your
barbecue I judged a burger competition
won Hell's Kitchen it was no one no one
could cook it was I'm sure yours will be
better there's my secret right here put
a little bit of mayonnaise on I do yeah
I do
mustard and ketchup really don't have a
place on a burger I think wow that's a
bold statement
I think mustard is best on hot dogs this
is gonna be the difference between mine
and yours people are gonna go wow really
wow about that undercooked bacon this is
gonna get dangerous all good now do you
make burgers for any famous people that
come in your restaurant all the time
[ __ ] yours are pretty we almost died in
the making but we did it damn it did it
they just looked like you hole punched a
burger bun okay they're both very tiny I
love tiny things so this one I'm gonna
try first and it has a little thing to
put on top of it which makes me feel
boozy predominantly tastes like cheese
but it's good it tastes like like a
little tiny slider all right get the
flavors though are pretty good I don't
know I feel pretty mad about that one I
think this little sauce made a
difference wow this is good whoever made
this one has more confidence because
they didn't need a topping it's that
very neatly you got some green you got
some yellow you got some red oh I like
this one a lot that's my winner
sometimes simple is better this one to
me is more savory I think this one I am
[ __ ] sugar
[Music]